as i was saying what i want to kind of
cover is it's looking a little bit lower
than we would normally look at asp.net
core so typically most people
will be familiar with working with maybe
the mvc pattern and using controllers
and actions
in your applications um and a lot of
that just works almost by magic you
don't have to do a huge amount of
wiring up or code there's a lot of
conventions that mean
asp.net core functions as you'd expect
what i want to do is dive into what's
actually happening under there
so that we can start to think about
places where we might be able to
replace some of the default behavior
with our own behavior
typically for achieving some kind of
cross-cutting concern that you have
in the application so we're going to
begin and we're going to begin right
from the very start of this journey
where a client
wants to make a http request to us so
let's imagine
that we've got an api running on
stevejordan.k
forward slash api forward slash books
and the client wants to communicate
with that api and get some data from it
so the very first stage that we'll just
touch on very briefly and i apologize
the the animations in this slide i spent
hours on
are going to be really janky over about
five frames per second that we get on
webex
but let's do our best to kind of follow
the pattern so the first phase is the
client has this address for a server
and it needs to understand where that
server actually is what server serves
that traffic
so we're not going to go diving deep
into dns but fundamentally there's a
you know a set of lookups and referrals
that may happen through various levels
of the domain name system
until we come to a domain name server
that can provide us back
an ip address that we can communicate
with so now we know the ip address of
the server that hosts the website
next we need to connect to that server
and the client that might be a browser
client being controlled by an actual
user
or it may be a programmatic client maybe
it's c sharp using http
current in the code base to communicate
with an api
it needs to connect to that server so a
port is going to be selected on the
client machine for the outbound
connection and then on the web server
we'll either be talking over
http which will typically use port 80 or
https over 443 so in this case let's
imagine we're doing
uh the sort of https because this is
going to be going over a public internet
so the first thing that happens is we
need to connect the client to the server
and we're going to use tcp so while
we're using http as our application
layer protocol
underneath that we have the
communication protocol the transport
protocol
of tcp and so there's a brief client
server handshake that takes place
client basically says hello are you
there the servers are here
and then we establish our connection now
there's another layer that we then need
to have on top of this because of the
secured
communications that we want so we layer
in the tls slab
and this requires another set of
handshaking to happen between client and
server
client basically is going to get a
certificate from the server to verify
that they are who they say they are
we'll do a decision on how we're
actually going to encrypt traffic and
what key exchange we're going to use for
that
and then eventually we'll have our tls
connection
the next stage is that the client needs
to send the actual http request
over the wire so here is a very basic
http request
it's basically just ascii test so in the
first line here we have the get
method being defined so this is the http
method that we're going to be using for
the request
the resource that we want slash api
slash books
and then the protocol version so 1.1 of
http
then we can have some headers these are
basically key value pairs
so here we have the host header defined
steve jordan.coding okay so this will
allow the routing system further down
uh and maybe even the web server to
determine okay which actual
maybe virtual website am i hosting on my
uh
on my server that can handle this
request so this will help with that
routing
and we have a number of fairly common
headers so accept header is like we
prefer
json in this exchange we prefer the
english language we can accept encodings
that allow supportion uh supporting of
compression for the request as well
and the response and we also identify
who we are with a user agent here
so this is us being a good citizen and
saying yeah this is kind of who we are
this is the version of us that's talking
to you so that the downstream service
knows
who we are and then we conclude the
request with
a blank line all of this so far we don't
have to worry about doing if you're
using something like http client to send
the request
it's doing all of this work for you uh
with a sort of an abstraction over what
the request message looks like
next we actually send the request over
the network to the
server that we've connected to and at
the other end of that connection in
asp.net core we have kestrel
kestrel has been there since asp.net
core 1.0
it was at the time a brand new web
server written from the ground up by the
asp.net team
and designed to be very efficient and
support running the
web server in process with the web
application so fundamentally asp.net
core applications are just
a console application it's a console
application that runs a host
that host is the process in the
application that basically keeps that
process alive
listening for things like down signals
from the operating system
and then within the host that can fire
up a web server
and kestrel conforms to the iserver
interface that's defined by that
set of hosting layer and can actually
act in as a server it binds itself to
whatever ports it's been told to
and listens for requests coming in
so what this looks like at quite a high
level is that the client is going to
make its request potentially over the
internet potentially over
an internal network to the kestrel web
server
on uh for on the connection that it's
established
uh kestrel then handles all of these
requests and these connections through
a series of connection middleware now
we're not going to go too deep into
connection middleware and how that all
works
inside kestrel it's quite a deep topic
but just be aware that if you have
particular networking requirements or
connection requirements
you can actually write your own
connection middleware and register
into the kestrel's kind of request
handling pipeline pretty like much like
you would middleware inside ash connect
core what we'll be talking about shortly
guess we're going to pass that request
then into asp.net core itself
asp.net core is going to do some work
hopefully producing a response
and then that response flows back out
through the connection that it's
established with the client
if we zoom in a little bit we'll have a
look at what happens in a little bit
more detail
so the request has come in it's reached
kestrel kestrel's first job
is to parse the http request so it's
getting bytes
over the network and it needs to
interpret those bytes
as a valid http message so this involves
various steps of parsing the request
line making sure that it includes the
method
the resource the protocol version
parsing out any headers that may be on
the request
possibly reading any content in if it's
a request with content
and ultimately its job is to translate
that into
a http context so this is the object
representation that basically covers all
of the information that we need through
the rest of the system
about the ongoing request so this is
essentially the contract between
kestrel and asp.net core so this carries
with it things like
details of what headers were found on
the request message what resource are
they looking for so what path or query
string maybe did they include in the url
and later on other bits of information
get tagged onto this context as it flows
through the system
there's a features collection this is
something that you can use in your
middleware and in your applications
if you want to apply a feature that
basically gets carried around a state
with that context
and flows through the rest of the
request handling pipeline
so this context flows into asp.net core
and your application code
you basically create the response within
there and that gets attached to the http
context
which gets passed back to kestrel and
then sent over the wire
if we zoom in even further we can see
what happens
after we've got that http context so the
next stage inside asp.net core itself
is that we're actually going to flow
that request and it's hdb context
into asp.net core middleware so asp.net
core middleware is a series of
components
basically that have access to the
request on the way in
and the response on the way out so why
is this
useful well middleware basically is a
great place for any kind of
cross-cutting behaviors cross-cutting
concerns for requests and responses
you register your middleware pipeline
and that gets read at startup
and used for the lifetime of that
application and so this means you
control exactly what happens to each
request as it flows through your system
each piece of middleware may choose to
simply pass the request on to the next
middleware
in the pipeline it might enrich the
request message so
maybe even change values or add on items
to the http context
or features to the features collection
and then it will
pass it on with that change or it may
choose to short circuit the pipeline
torque circuiting is basically where the
middleware decides actually i can return
some kind of valid response so it will
set the response message
on the context and then not pass it on
to the next middleware in the chain
instead it will return back to kestrel
so each piece of middleware runs in turn
and eventually once that middleware
pipeline is run it's going to hand off
to
some endpoint or usually mvc for the
rest of the request handling
once that's built a response it flows
back through the middleware and this is
important it flows through the
middleware again but in reverse order
from what you originally registered it
and so each piece of middleware now has
the opportunity to inspect the response
that's been added onto that contact
and maybe make decisions about it maybe
do some kind of metrics and monitoring
uh based on what response is going out
of your server
about any kind of cross-cutting concern
that you have and then again
that flows out over to the client
so this is how we define a middleware
pipeline in a standard application so
this is the configure method of the
startup class so you will hopefully have
seen this if you've used asp.net core
before
this is the typical example out of one
of the templates
and the configure method has access to
the eye application builder this is the
way that we define all of the pipeline
for processing our requests
so we add middleware to that pipeline
with these various app.use
something methods so if we take a look
at this first one for example this one
adds in the developer exception page
middleware and this middleware basically
takes a
request that's had an exception phone
somewhere in the system and writes out
the stack trace
so that's really useful during
development to understand what went
wrong and where it blew up
but that's not something we want to leak
out into the public internet we wouldn't
want to give people a sort of detailed
understanding of
how our application works internally it
might be an attack vector
so this piece of middleware is
registered conditionally by checking the
environment we're running in so this app
starts up
the configure method gets called and at
that point asp.net core has established
what environment it's running in
based on environment variables and
config settings
the other thing you can use here to
potentially opt in or out of middleware
at sort of
startup is putting uh conditions around
your middleware registrations that use
the eye configuration as well so
configuration features that you might
have set in your app settings.json could
control
the startup order for your application
the next piece of middleware use https
redirection
is a piece of middleware which sort of
produces an example of where we might
short circuit the request so this
middleware
sees the request coming in and if the
scheme of that request
is http and not https then this
piece of middleware is not going to pass
the request on for the rest of the
pipeline
instead what it's going to do is send
back a redirect to the client and say
actually no
you need to be using this url that uses
https
so this is how https is enforced in
asp.net core applications
so that's a middleware that sort of
makes that selective decision based on
interpreting
some of the data that's on the request
in the http context
we'll come back to some of these other
ones in a while but if we draw that
sort of uh sort of set of middleware out
as a diagram this is kind of what it
looks like
so we have the pipeline being invoked on
the left and then middleware gets him
called in the order it was registered
top to bottom of the configure method
now there's one interesting thing on
this diagram that some of you may be
spotting
and that's two pieces of middleware show
up here that aren't in the configure
method
and these get registered in a special
way by a different part
of asp.net core's startup system
there's a feature in there called i
startup filter and this is
sorry a startup filter and this is an
interface that you can implement
in your applications and register with
the di container
and when asp.net core starts up it will
run each of those startup filters
and the goal of the startup filter is to
register middleware into the pipeline
right at the beginning of that pipeline
so it doesn't give you as much control
over the placement and ordering of the
middleware but certain kinds of
middleware do lend themselves to this
so the two examples that microsoft place
in there by default is host filtering
which is going to look at the host
header and see if it matches the allowed
hosts for that application
so in your appsettings.json you can
define what hosts
your web servers should actually respond
for by default it puts in a star so it
allows any host
but if you do start adding in hosts
hostnames that you support
those will get filtered out via that
piece of middleware very early in the
pipeline
the next one is about dealing with
forwarded headers from things like
reverse proxies so
typically we'll put our asp.net core
applications behind some kind of load
balancer maybe even a reverse proxy like
nginx
or we may run it behind at iis um and if
you do
those are typically going to add sort of
exported four type headers onto the
request
and what we can do in this middleware is
translate those into the
standard headers that has connect calls
are looking for
so once the endpoint that gets the
request
handles it and send a response that
response then flows back through that
middleware pipeline
this time in reverse order
we can write our own middleware and the
middleware is
basically in line in this example so we
can use the app.used method here to
register this inline middleware we get
access to
a context which is the http context and
the next variable here relates to the
request delegate which is the next piece
of middleware in the pipeline
so inside this method we can write logic
that controls the behavior of this
application when it's handling requests
this example is fairly basic so what
we're going to do is start a stopwatch
as soon as the request comes to us
and then immediately pass it on to the
next middleware in the pipeline
that will flow through all of the
middleware somewhere the response will
be generated
the response will generally flow back
through the middleware until it reaches
us
at which point we stop our stopwatch and
in this case just record a metric
this is a very sort of low-tech way of
adding sort of uh
response timing metrics into an
application um i do something a bit like
this in a real application just slightly
more
sophisticated the only problem with this
is we do need a service from di
and although we can get to that by going
on to the context accessing request
services which is the iservice provider
and then calling get required service
we're kind of using the service locator
pattern here which
isn't super clean so for anything but
really basic middleware
i tend to recommend following the
pattern of creating a middleware class
this is a
class this is basically your middleware
component and the other thing you can do
with these is add them into libraries
you get packages and share them around
your business if you have common
features that you want to apply to lots
of applications
this doesn't require a particular
interface it's all done by a sort of
convention and duct typing
so this method um constructor here must
accept
a request delegate and that is the
representation of the next piece of
middleware in the pipeline
anything else that we want to take from
di we can also have injected into here
then we have the invoke async method and
we also must provide this
and it must accept the http context
representing the current request
the code inside here is basically what
we just looked at in line
except now we're using the dependency
injected iometric recorder
and our code has all now been nicely
wrapped up in this single class
to call this from our application code
then we can now use the
use middleware extension method on the
eye application builder
to register our middleware so in this
example we're registering this really
early in the pipeline
so we can time the end to end request
if you want to get a little bit cleaner
with that kind of stuff and you're
building maybe libraries you're sharing
around
a good sort of best practice there is to
build these extension methods on the our
application builder
so inside your extension method you just
call use middleware
but now this means that as a caller when
they're adding this into the pipeline
it's just a little bit cleaner a little
bit clearer what's being added and all
of those
middleware that we're seeing added by
default use this convention of providing
an extension method for registering the
middleware
the next thing i want to talk about is
endpoint routing and this is quite a
deep topic
um it could probably sort of take up a
whole
session in its own uh but what i'm going
to do is try and give you the highlights
so in asp.net core 2.2 the team
introduced this
endpoint routing feature before asp.net
core 2.2 what would happen is the
request would flow through middleware
and the final piece of middleware would
be
mvc middleware usually and the mvc
middleware would receive the request and
then
use the sort of mvc part of the
framework to actually process the
request
and inside there mvc would do all of the
logic for figuring out where that
request should root
are you which controller and which
action now that worked just worked just
fine but the problem is it meant that
mvc is the only component in the entire
sort of application pipeline
that can actually know where a request
is going to be rooted i what controller
and what action
and this means that if we want to do
something like authorization for example
we can't do that until we're inside mvc
because we haven't determined yet which
action is going to get invoked
and if if we know what once we know what
that action is we can determine does it
require authorization and if so what
level of authorization
so what the team did in 2.2 which wasn't
on by default
um but has since been switched on and
made the default pattern in three zero
and 3.1
is introduce endpoint routing so with
endpoint routing
all of the routing logic has been lifted
up outside of mvc so it stands alone
as additional middleware in the
application and what this means is we
can do
further things based on that routing
with inside the middleware pipeline
directly
so the easiest way to come try and
understand this is to take a look at the
digger method again so the first piece
of middleware for routing
is newsrooting and this piece of
middleware when the application is
running
it's responsible for interpreting what
the request is
looking for so is it a get request and
what's the path it's going to be
and matching that to one of the known
routes for the application
but no routes get figured out at startup
but they can also be updated
at runtime as well so use routing is
about figuring out what endpoint is
going to be called
the further down middleware here use
endpoints is about actually invoking
that endpoint so now we know where we're
going to send this request
send it there the bit that is slightly
confusing is that within use endpoints
you have this delegate to
set up the endpoints so this doesn't
actually happen
as the app's running this kind of
happens earlier and in this case we're
using the convenience method map
controllers
which basically means that startup the
application is going to locate all of
the controllers in the assembly
find all of the action methods that
relate to those controllers
and then figure out how they should map
to routing
uh so you know are they get methods are
they uh what route attributes do they
have and that will build up this routing
table
so these two pieces work together what
this means is that between these two
pieces of middleware we're kind of in
what they call the routing zone this is
where we have middleware
that now knows where this request is
going to end up
and this means that these two pieces of
middleware are what we call endpoint
aware
so this means that they both can
understand what
endpoint this request is going to end up
at and also have a bunch of metadata
about that endpoint
that allow them to determine if they
need to take action so use authorization
for example didn't exist
as middleware before 3.0 because it had
to happen inside
mvc now it's middleware because it can
look at the request it can tell which
endpoint that's going to map to
and it will be able to check if there's
an authorized attribute for example on
the action method
and if there is but the user hasn't
logged in then we can return the
challenge response to them because we
know that they're not allowed to see
that without logging in
the easiest way to get a bit of a feel
for how this works and excuse me sort of
leaning in as i uh as i demo this is to
actually look
uh as a little sample app um all of the
slides
and all of the code i'm going to show
you is online i'll make sure i point out
the link at the end
and i'll share it in the chat as well so
you can get a look at all of this
so inside my startup class in my little
sample app here i've got
two pools to use middleware so i've got
one here before
use routing and one after use routing
it's the same piece of middleware but
we're going to run it once
before we use routing and once after if
we take a look at the code for this
um it's a fairly simple piece of
middleware
and when invoke async gets called what
it's going to do is it's going to
first call get endpoint on the http
context
and so if endpoint routing has uh sorry
use routing has already been called
and it's matched this to an endpoint
this will contain details about what
about what that endpoint is if it hasn't
matched then this would just be null
so in this piece of middleware i'm just
uh conditionally dumping data out to the
logs so i'm saying if it's a type root
endpoint which is the type that
action methods typically are maps to
then
write out the display name the root
pattern that matched it and any metadata
and if it's null we'll just write that
out
now if i run this code in postman
i'm just going to make a request to one
of my endpoints here and this is coming
through that middleware this is coming
through the first time so this is before
we pulled
um use routine so here the endpoint is
null
because user routing hasn't yet run to
match this to a particular endpoint so
at this point we can't really do
anything based on that root information
but if i continue it will flow through
this the first middleware it'll flow
through user routing and it will come
back in
to our second registration of this same
middleware and this time
we do have an endpoint so this endpoint
has some metadata
we know that this is going to go to the
books controller and the get method
uh we have a bunch of metadata which is
just really a collection of any kind of
object that we know about this endpoint
so in this case we can see all of the
attributes that apply to the controller
and the actions within it
and so this allows us to make decisions
by inspecting this
uh if we can fly out certain metadata we
might be able to decide on what to do
so for example if we had the authorize
attribute on an action method
that would show up here and that's
exactly what use authorization is using
to make determinations about whether or
not someone's allowed to continue their
request or not
i'll just continue that request and
greatly we've got a response there
so after we've run all of the middleware
pipeline and the application
moved through um we're going to then
enter into
mvc so mvc is the programming paradigm
that hopefully many of you are familiar
with
it's the model view controller approach
it is this is used for
web api development still where we have
these models and controllers
you can use it for ui applications if
you're applying views as well
and razer pages itself sits on top of
this model and it's kind of a layer over
the top
so inside mvc we have
controllers and this is a basic example
so a controller
can derive from controller base which
provides it some default behaviors that
we might need
we have the api controller attribute
which is going to add some features on
for apis
using some of the techniques we're about
to see it has the root attribute
so this is how the routing system uh
when it's mapping the controller roots
can determine what the root should be in
this case the square brackets and
controller
means use the name so slash books
without the controller suffix
and inside here we can inject things via
dependency injection if we want to
and we can then create action methods
any public method of a controller
is considered an action method by
default so in this case the action
method is a get it doesn't have
any parameters it has the http get
attribute which ensures that
uh only get requests will map to this
endpoint and it returns some kind of i
action result
in this case we're using the action
result of t which basically says we're
going to return a result with some data
and this is the type of that data
and in this case it's using uh the ok
method here which comes from the
controller base
that's going to translate to an ok
object result
and that object result has an object in
this case it's the the list of books
that we've retrieved from some
repository system
don't worry too much about action
results at the moment we'll be getting
to them in a moment
so next uh we'll just take a quick dive
into mvc at a 10
000 foot view before we go a little bit
deeper
so once we enter mvc some code is going
to run and eventually
uh the controller factory is going to
need to create an instance of the
controller so this is where we
initialize and instance the controller
her request once we have the controller
some more code will run and eventually
an action invoker will kick in
and that that job there is to actually
call your action method so whatever
method has mapped to the request that's
being handled after that we have that by
action result and the i action result
doesn't represent
data at this point it represents a
strongly typed model
of what data and what type of http
response we may be
sending only gets converted into a
actual http response
when we execute the i action result and
that happens in the result execution
phase
finally that data then gets returned so
in the case of an api
normally we're just going to return
serialized json data
if you're doing uh something with views
then the view rendering phase takes
place here so the
view result which takes the view and the
model and kind of
combines them together and then executes
them to produce html will run
we're going to be focusing more on the
data result option here
so what happens after uh we enter mvc is
we basically run through what's called
the filter pipeline it is a pipeline
that handles how
mvc sort of responds to requests
internally
and you can kind of think of this really
a very big state machine nvc is
basically a state machine
that runs through different states as
the request flows through
uh bumping it through the various states
until it flows back out again
so where this starts from um is we have
the middleware
on the left there which represents the
you know the middleware pipeline that
we've already seen
and the request is going to flow from
the left
so the first thing that happens inside
mvc is high authorization filters will
get executed
so eye authorization filters are a place
where we can run
authorization code in the on
authorization method
now because of endpoint routing today
these pretty much will probably do
nothing because now use authorization is
its own middleware
and has probably already run then the
authorization filters will be able to
detect that
and won't run again only if uh use
authorization hasn't been called earlier
would authorization kick in inside the
mvc feature set itself
you can write your own authorization
filter you implement eye authorization
filter
but it's really not recommended to do so
the reason for that is there's a whole
authorization system inside asp.net core
that's built to be
very pluggable and very controllable so
the recommended pattern if you need to
customize authorization logic is to use
authorization policies
and authorization handlers maybe even
resource base off but all of those are
kind of higher level features
and the eye authorization filter that's
registered by default will kick in
and execute those policies for us so
don't normally want to be modifying
these
authorization filters might
short-circuit the pipeline so if someone
isn't allowed to um run then they will
be getting the forbidden result in this
case
because we've said actually the thing
you're trying to access you're not
allowed to see
the next filter in the pipeline is
resource filters
so these kick in immediately after
authorization will have run
and they have an on resource executing
method and at this point again we can do
some additional
cross-cutting concerns that wrap the
entire mvc request response pipeline
excuse me the only problem with this is
that again this is
a feature that's kind of been taken away
now we have the concept of
endpoint aware middleware it's better to
write middleware that inspects the
endpoints and makes
conditional decisions about whether it
runs or not previously the reason you'd
use an eye resource filter
is because you'd want to know and you
would know at this stage which
controller and which action is going to
get the request
so resource filters do allow us some
functionality though and we'll take a
look at one shortly
again a resource filter can
short-circuit the pipeline if it wants
to
returning some kind of result and then
if not it will pass the request into the
rest of mvc
nvc is going to do all of its work and
it's going to return the response and on
the way out on resource executed gets
called and we have another final
opportunity
to potentially change or augment
behavior based on the result that's
going out
so let's have a look at another quick
demo here
so what i'm going to do is look at an
example of a very basic resource tool
so in this example uh what i'm doing if
i just make this fit
onto the large font size um so this is
an iron
resource filter um it's got an on
resource executing method that we're
using and what we're saying in here is
read the response see if there's a
request header called preview
and if there is what's it that is value
so the idea is that we're going to have
a section of our api
that isn't behind authorization but that
does require
someone to opt into accessing it because
it's not yet complete
so we're saying if they haven't got the
preview header or if they've got the
header and it's
false then we're going to short circuit
the pipeline we do that by setting the
result on the context so here we're
saying
just pretend that you couldn't find the
resource turn the not found result
otherwise we'll just continue through
and we'll just add a response header
and by default because we haven't set
the context the mvc state machine will
just pass this on
to either the next filter or to the next
part of the processing pipeline
the way i've applied this resource
filter is i've got this author's
controller in my application
and in this case i've added my my filter
to the controller
so you can add filters either to action
methods
or to entire controllers so all action
methods of the controller
or globally for all actions or
controllers
so here we said apply this to anything
under authors
that we want that feature so this is the
method we're going to call here
so hopefully we'll make our request and
i haven't set any preview headers at the
moment so i make my request
and we get a 404 not found response
what's interesting is we never even hit
this action method so because
we had a filter in place that
short-circuited this request pipeline
it never even made it as far as an
action method if i add on a preview
header here that has the value of true
and resend this request through you can
see now it does hit the action method
inside here because it passed through
the filter and if i continue that
um you can see that we get the the fake
data from this endpoint
so this is one of the ways that we can
filter that behavior now today we could
write that with
endpoint aware middleware because we
could also look for the presence of an
attribute on the metadata
after the use routing has been called
and we could have middleware that then
says if this attribute is present
apply this same behavior
we'll come back to slides and we'll
continue the journey shortly
uh so the next filter is middle air
filters and these are really just a
special kind of resource filter and you
might wonder
why we have a filter for middleware when
we can run middleware in the pipeline
and this again stems from the pre
endpoint routine
days where we might want to apply some
middleware but only selectively to some
endpoints
and the only way to do that before
endpoint routing was to do it inside the
mvc pipeline where we knew the end point
where we knew the controller and action
that we were going to invoke so again
middleware filters may short-circuit the
pipeline
here's a very basic example we're not
going to use one uh in the demos because
it's pretty much depreciated now
but basically what you do is create a
class that has a configure method so
very much like the signature of the
startup class
and in there you have the eye
application builder and you call various
methods to add in the
middleware that you want um in this case
we're adding the response compression
middleware only
and then to conditionally apply that to
a controller you use the middleware
filter attribute
passing in the type of the middleware
pipeline that you want to use
and so this means in this example
anything that goes through the office
controller
will also run that additional middleware
to potentially apply
response compression so all of these
first three filters are places we can
customize logic
but they're all places where the
behavior of doing so
has pretty much been replaced by using
endpoint routing
and the endpoint aware middleware so if
you find yourself writing these
do have a think and see oh can we do
this if we do get endpoint in our
middleware
and then we look at the attributes that
are on those endpoints can we make the
same
sort of decisions about whether we're
filtering the requests and doing
something special with them or not
so the next phase after this initial
step is the controller creations this is
where the
factory for creating controllers is
going to run it's going to create an
instance of the controller for that
particular request
and then the next phase begins which is
all around invoking the action on that
on that controller that we're going to
be sending the request through
so the first piece of that and one of
the most important is model binding
we have to map any data that we need off
of a request
and match it to parameters of the action
method because
the action method we've looked at so far
had no parameters but it's very common
for example you might have an endpoint
that allows you to get data about one
particular book
and that might take an int id as one of
its parameters
and so somehow mvc needs to work out
what id you want to pass into that
action method when it gets invoked
and that's where model binding comes in
so mvc has a suite of model binders
by default and many of these will handle
sort of 99 of your scenarios the model
binders are basically responsible for
saying okay given this type that i'm
trying to
create so maybe the int id do i have a
model binder that can
provide integers and map them off of the
request
so there's a simple type model binder
that's responsible for these kind of
basic operations
and potentially making sure that the
data coming in on that request could be
set to the value so it's easier to see
that in a little bit of an example so
here we've got a search method
which has two parameters we have a
string
keyword and an int page size so somehow
when this action method is invoked we
need that
data we need those parameters so mvc has
a series of what are known as value
providers and these are the the things
that basically inspect parts of the
request like the query string
like the headers and see if there's
values on there that could potentially
fulfill the requirements of the action
method
so here for example we require a keyword
on the string so the value providers are
going to be asked do you have a value
that could potentially satisfy this
well value providers are essentially a
key value sort of lookup so they say
well yeah i've got something called
keyword
here's its value i'll pump that into
this action method when we invoke it
integers very similar
so here we have a page size that matches
on the query string as well
and as long as the value of that is a
valid integer that could also be used to
satisfy this request
where things get more complex is when
you've got um sort of strongly typed
input models for things like post
requests so if we have an endpoint that
allows us to post a book into the system
we'll probably accept maybe a book input
model and on there we'll have a number
of properties like id
title isbn number for example so we need
to get those
bound from the data on the request and
most likely that data exists
in the actual request body so this is
where input formatters come in
input formatters can look at the content
type of the request coming in
and determining can i take that content
and can i turn it into an object
so in the case of mvc by default there's
a json input formatter that's registered
so if the content type is application
json
the model binder will use the input
formatter for json
to try and deserialize the content of
the request body
and turn it into whatever object we're
trying to bind
and so we can use the default input
formatter for json we can add a default
formatter that is included in the box
but not enabled for xml
or you can write your own if you've got
uh requirements use protobuf or message
pack or your own
proprietary binary serialization format
you can write a formatter
to interpret that data off of the
request
let's have a quick look at model binding
we won't spend too long on this because
again it's a feature that you can easily
overuse
um but i have one example that i have
used in practice that i think is fairly
reasonable so here i've got a method
which allows us to search for
a set of books by the the date range
that they were published within
so my method accepts this date range
type if we take a look at date range
we'll see it's a fairly simple struct
it's got a start date and an end date
the important thing is these are read
only so these are getters but no setters
so the only way to create this object is
through the constructor and then from
then on it's considered immutable
and in here we do some logic around um
the date as well so the end date can't
be before the start date that wouldn't
be valid for our day range concept
now one option if we wanted to avoid
custom model binding here is that we
could just have a simpler type that does
have a getter and a set of
two properties basically an input model
and we could map to that and then we
could try and create our mutable date
range as our domain model
inside our controller and generally for
more complex types that's
pretty reasonable but for something as
simple as this where we might use this
across a number of action methods in our
in our controllers this makes makes
quite a lot of sense
so if we take a look at what the binder
looks like quickly
here we basically have the code for
binding and i won't
talk about every step here i'll try and
summarize it and you can take a look at
the comments in the code yourself
afterwards
basically what we're saying is when
you're trying to bind
we expect by convention in our system
the start date and then data have these
names on
on some of the data however it's
provided that could be in query string
it could be on the root parameters for
example
so then what we say is we ask them the
value provider system do you have any
values with these keys these names and
it will return to us a result which can
be
none one or many values that match
in this case if if we've got none we
haven't got the values we want what
we're going to do is we're going to add
a model error
to the model state so the model state is
a representation of how the binding has
gone basically
and mvc can use this for future uh
validation steps in
handling the response so the model state
here we add an error saying okay we
didn't find the start of date or end
date something
failed we set the result as failed and
we simply return
otherwise if we do have those values we
set the model state to say yep we found
the values these are the values we're
going to use
we then access those values which are by
default strings
so then we then pass those strings to
dates because
a date should conform to a sort of
well-known date structure
and if we parse them and they're both
been able to be parsed correctly
now we can create our date range object
here
and so this date range object uh takes
the start date and end date
then we set the result on the binding
context as successful and we set the
object that we successfully bound
if this fails so if there's an argument
exception because the end date's invalid
for
example then we'll again set model state
as failed and we'll add a model error
there
so that's pretty much the binder there's
two ways we can add binding support to
an application so the first is in
the configure services method when we
add nvc or we add controllers
in this example we can add to the model
binder provider list
a model binder provider specifically for
our requirements
we insert this one in position zero so
it runs first
and this model binder provider is a
fairly simple class that implements our
model binder provider
and it then has this get binder method
and on here we get access to the model
type that's trying to be bound
and so our comparison is if it's a date
range yes we can supply a date range
binder for that
if not we'll return null which means we
haven't found a suitable binder
and then the other providers will get
asked can you can you match this then
this works if you don't own the type in
this example we own
the date range struct so what we can
actually do is add an attribute directly
to it
that controls the model binder that's
used as well so if you own the type
this attribute-based approach is quite
straightforward
if you don't own the type and it's from
some external library and you can't
modify it
then maybe you would use the model
binder provider approach
so let's see how this works if i go to
another endpoint that we're going to
call so by range
we provide the start date and an end
date and we're going to make the request
you can see yep we get we get a result
if um i change the date on this so that
the start date
is earlier than the end date which we
consider invalid in our system
and send again uh you'll see now we get
a 400 valve request from the system
and it gives us the detail of what's
failed in our model so because we've
added this custom model binder in we've
added this additional logic i'll undo
that so i don't forget in a moment
after model binding has run uh the next
phase is
action filters so these implement the i
action filter interface
these are basically like the filters
that have come before them
the main difference is at this point we
know the bound parameters of the
the request so we have actual actual
access to those bound arguments
basically
and we can look at those values and make
decisions about whether we let requests
continue
so this is another place where you might
apply some kind of validation logic
we'll look at that shortly again they
may choose to short-circuit the
request path um and just immediately
return
otherwise what they're going to do is
execute the action method
so this is where mvc and the framework
is just actually going to call finally
your action method code anything that
you've written inside that action method
and so in some applications this may be
the first place in the entire pipeline
after all of this stuff is run
where it's actually running user code
code you've provided
everything else could all be the default
middleware and the default motherbikers
so the action method gets invoked and
after it gets invoked we get the on
action executed called on the filter so
again it's another
sort of double uh double filter we're on
the way in and on
the way out so again we'll have a quick
look at a a short demo for this one
so let's take this binding scenario a
little bit further so
on my books controller where i accept
this we accept a date range and we've
validated it's about a date range
through binding it
but maybe in this action method and
maybe in more than just this action
method we have a requirement that we
only allow the date range to be two
years
because maybe looking up anything more
than two years is too much data for some
reason
and so if we had to apply that once we
could do it inside this action method we
could compare the start and end date and
if it's greater than two years
return some kind of bad request result
but if we want to do that in multiple
action methods
that's going to be code that we'd have
to repeat so let's let's be dry and not
repeat ourselves
so what we can do is we can create a
filter which i've applied in this case
to this particular action method
two year date range filter and in here
the logic
is fairly straightforward as well so on
action executing
we're going to see if the action
arguments contains a value called date
range
and if so is it a type date range and if
it is
is that date range greater than two
years if it's greater than two
years then instead of actually passing
this through we're going to short
circuit by setting the results again
and we're going to set a bad request
object result here so this is a
bad request with some payload and in
this case it's a problem details
response that includes the error message
so now if i uh make a request to my
endpoint again but this time
uh well there we go we've already got
2012 on there in 2019 so that's greater
than two years
if i make my request now instead of
hitting the action method
it's been filtered out um it's probably
even easier to see that if i put
a breakpoint on here so this is the
action method if we do that one more
time
it's immediately been returned the
response by short circuiting inside the
the filter mechanism
so this is cross-cutting concerns in the
case of our application that we've been
able to apply
as a filter
we're nearly there after action filters
um and after action execution
there is the possibility that our action
method threw an exception so
we had some kind of exception in our
code or code that we called down into
that we haven't appropriately handled so
obviously we don't want to blow up the
entire
web server just because one request has
caused an exception
so exception filters are about dealing
with those exception cases
and setting an appropriate response
there is a default behavior inside mvc
that
will handle this for us but if you want
to you can write your own iexception
filter
and in its on exception method control
what happens
so back to the demo and let's take a
look at that example
so here is my exception filter
you can see it inherits from i exception
filter it has a non-exception method
and in here what i'm choosing to do is
record a metric to a metric system
so this is a really good use case for
this which is if an exception occurs in
the application that's unhandled
wouldn't it be nice if our alerting and
monitoring system knew about that and
could maybe alert us in slack or
something
well this is exactly what we do in our
system so we have
an exception occurring we record a
metric and then downstream our
notifications come out
the other thing we're doing here is
we've got our own custom format in this
api
or what an error message looks like so
this is the model for that error
has a message and it has a flag is error
so inside our code we actually can
construct and return an instance of that
as a
serialized json object and then we just
set this exception handle to true
so that any other exception filters know
actually
we can register this is we can add it to
controllers or actions but i've
registered this one in my startup class
into this filters collection so this is
where we add filters globally that apply
to
all controllers and all actions which is
really useful for something like
exception handling
so with that exception in the framework
if i come in and make a call to an
endpoint
uh called bang we'll run that
we've got an unhandled exception here
now this could be deep down into our
code but the only way to prevent this
with our own code would be to wrap this
in a try catch and that
may not be very pretty if you have to
have a try catch in every action method
so by adding our filter handling we
don't need to try catch we catch the
exception in the exception filter
instead
so if we let this continue um and why
that's run twice
uh the request comes through and you can
see here our nicely formatted exception
message that we decided to return
as a signature of this api
so we're coming towards the end uh but
we're still
a little bit more in the in the pipeline
so after all of this is run the final
set of filters that are
going to run are result filters so the
main difference
with what these have access to that we
didn't have access to earlier is we now
have
the action result with the iaction
result that was returned by our action
method
assuming there was no exception so the i
action result is that
sort of representation of the data that
our response is going to include
but it hasn't yet been written to the
response content so at this point we can
in this filter make some further
decisions based on the type of action
result
or even the data within the action
result
if we have a cross-cutting concern we'll
look at one in a second
but action filter sorry result filters
run and then the action result itself
gets executed and this is where
um in an api for example the action
result is going to be turned into the
appropriate response probably
with a json payload so the way that
works is if your request includes an
object
sorry your result includes an object
that that object is going to run through
an output formatter
by default that will be the json output
formatter
and that will serialize the object to
json and then add that onto the
response stream you can again add your
own output formatters so if you want to
send a different type of data you can do
that
by adding that formatter into the
framework uh for again protobuf message
pack or some custom proprietary format
that you have
and at this stage now on the hp context
we have
the http response uh with the data added
to it so
headers will have been added and the
actual content will be written out to it
and then the request sorry the response
now flows through back through that
middleware
um filter pipeline all the way out to
the middle there at the end there
so let's have a look at one of those
result filters quickly and just get an
idea of where we could use those
so here i have a result filter this is
the last
modified result filter and what i'm
doing here is i'm saying if the result
type
is okay object result and if the value
of that so the object inside the ok
object result
is of type mutable output model base
which is a really terribly named type i
added
this is a base type that i use for my
output models in this example so this
includes a last modified date so we
assume anything that can be modified in
the database
will be mapped to a output model
that derived from this and here's the
rest of the book data
what this means is because we have this
kind of type that we can look for
we can now say well okay if it is that
time we'll set the last modified
response header to the last modified
uh value from the actual object so we're
having we're adding a header on here in
this example
this is why we do this on result
executing not executed because we need
to write the headers
before the output formatter writes the
response body
because we can't have headers after the
response body so this is going to run
and if we make a request to this
endpoint and send that request through
so we've got our response it includes
the last modified date
and on the headers here we've now added
our last modified header
um with the value that we we've bought
out of the database
and this this filter is again referenced
globally so this applies to
every controller and every action where
it's an object result being returned
of that type and so this is again
another place to apply this
cross-cutting concerns
and could even be used with certain
kinds of caching for example if you have
specific requirements to do so
so this is the kind of final picture
that was about as deep as we're gonna go
um there have been some generalizations
that i've had to make to fit this into
into the hour but the key points are
those first three filters
authorization resource and middleware
are pretty much redundant today with
endpoint routing
uh which you should be using if you're
using 3.0 or
3.1 um basically give us the same
functionality but lifted up
outside of mvc and so you can do
authorization with authorization
middleware
you can base your sort of resource
filter logic
inside middleware by making it endpoint
aware so
calling getendpoint on the context and
then interpreting
any attributes of that endpoint any
metadata about it
and similarly with middleware filters
you can conditionally apply your
middleware
controller creation is going to happen
and the first then phase is model
binding
so this is where again we map properties
and data from the request
onto the types and the um arguments
of our action method we then run the
action execution phase so this is where
the action invoker is going to run
and call our actual code so if you
haven't done any previous customization
this is the first chance where your code
is going to run we then get the
action result the i action result from
that action method
and before we execute it we run it
through a filter again so we can make a
final
last minute decision to do something
unusual and then if not we execute the
action result
which may or may not use an output
formatter to produce the
the serialized data that's going to go
on to the response and then all of this
flows back out of mvc
um as a response that's added onto that
http context
we flow back into the middleware so a
reminder we come out of whatever
endpoint whatever action method inside
mvc is called
and we flow through each of the
middleware and the response is set now
so those middleware components can
potentially log that information or
potentially do something
related to that data potentially decide
to even replace the response entirely
and then the hdd context flows to
kestrel
and kestrel is going to take that data
from the http context
turn it into a http response message as
bytes
that it sends down to the client just to
kind of close the picture
is the response message from our earlier
request so the server said great
i've been able to do this request for
you so it's a 200 okay response
it's included some headers so some of
these headers such as the server header
have been added by kestrel itself
some of these are going to be added via
sort of mdc's such as the content type
that we ended up creating and adding to
the response
and we've even got our last modified
header that we added
using our result filter inside asp.net
core
the response content then is the
serialized json representation
of an array of books in this example um
and so
this was produced by that output
formatter which saw the
the object that we attached to our
action result it saw the object
it knew how to serialize that into valid
json and then it attached it to the
http context and onto the response
so lots and lots of stuff there um the
main thing is don't
expect you need to use all of these
things in all of your applications
most of the time the defaults are going
to be working pretty well for you
but if there is code that you find
yourself repeating particularly across
numerous action methods do you think
about whether that could be better
applied as some kind of filter at the
appropriate place in the pipeline
and then just use attributes to apply
that behavior where you need it
in summary uh the requests are handled
in asp.net call by kestrel
so that's responsible for parsing bytes
off of the wire into a http context and
passing it into
the rest of the asp.net core and later
uh producing the bytes that go out back
out to the client
we have the middleware pipeline gets
executed in the order that they're
registered
so from top to bottom of the configure
method and the response flows back
through in the reverse order
and finally we have this concept of
endpoints which
is new in sort of 3.0 3.1 uh
endpoints are really just an action
that's going to invoke
and handle our request and that may run
through the filter pipeline first which
may or may not decide to short-circuit
that request handling eventually the
action method gets executed
which returns an i-action result and
then the action result is going to get
executed
to return the final contact
so lots and lots of stuff there um
terrible animations coming across
over five frames a second um the link
that i mentioned earlier so these slides
and all of the sample code which is up
on my github is at that link there
bit.ly forward slash asp.net anatomy
um that should take you to that and i've
included some other resources there
so some links to the microsoft
documentation that cover this stuff
pretty well as well
um you can find me online and perhaps
steve jay gordon on twitter so if you
have any questions that i haven't
kind of covered off i'll do my best to
answer them there um we've got like a
minute left here so i don't think we'll
probably do too many questions
on the chat but what i'll do is as soon
as we've uh kind of concluded
i'll jump into the slack channel for
this room
and we can kind of keep the discussion
going there or
over dms if you prefer if you if you
prefer to do that so
hopefully that was useful hopefully um
that's the information you were looking
for
um lots and lots of stuff there to take
away and apply to what you're building
thank you very much for coming along and
hopefully next year i will see you
in person at ndc osler thank you